welcome to Jaime Lerner it's a sort of a
it's really a great honor I think to
have Jamie with us here speaking tonight
and it's been actually an extended honor
because it's been working with group of
architecture and real estate students on
a project in Brazil and it's been an ink
for all of us unbelievably refreshing I
mean a little bit the problem with
introducing jamie is that he's what they
used to call a legend like The Legend
and rock and roll a legend in
architecture but so I feel obliged to
tell you things that you already know
but the thing about legends is you have
to you have to repeat these things but
before saying these things I think that
my real point is is that Jamie is just
simply one of the warmest most humorous
funniest creative and most intelligent
people you'll ever get a chance to meet
so basically what's so so important to
understand is how nice this person is
and then if you take somebody that's so
powerfully nice so tender and smart and
put that person in a series of very key
locations political strategic economic
social and so on things happen and
things happen around that person that
don't happen around other people and I
just want to insist it it has a lot to
do with the the pleasure it is to have a
drink with Jamie or to eat or to talk or
to laugh that's the pleasure of that
cities have had or institutions have had
or states of head or even architecture
as a field as head so in every way Jamie
is a leader quite literally a leader
like the mayor of Curitiba three times
it's actually sort of impossible to do
that it's impossible to be the mayor of
a Brazilian city three times in
different times governor of the state of
run or two times again it's impossible
not possible then the president of the
uia so that's the worst of all the head
of all the architects the International
Union of architects so really a leader
but in a much more important sensor
leader in ideas ideas that have become
almost standard practice like of course
the bus rapid transit system in the late
80s but there are actually many ideas
before that the idea of turning
floodplains into parks the ideas of
exchanging trash for groceries the idea
of saying to fishermen that they could
fish for trash and would be treated the
same as fish actually more valuable so
instead of fishing for a fish they
should fish with a trash that's making
it difficult for the fish to live and
eventually then they could fish again
and again as governor very similar
inventions in industry in education and
so on always it's something like big
ideas and small budgets which I can tell
you is is our language here in the
school we overcompensate for the size of
our budget with the size of our ideas
for sure so in this sense you are a
legend to us countless awards it will be
boring to list the awards but I think
maybe to listen to the sound of the
kinds of awards united nations
environmental award on the one hand on
the other hand the child and peace award
from UNICEF so each time actually the
award is in an entirely different area
the world technology award for
transportation right so it's it's or
standing it's going to be an annoying
person it's going to irritate a ting
that you can win awards in all of these
different areas at least you should be a
superstar in one area but not all of
these areas leave something for us
something small something small with a
big budget maybe the other way around
anyway of course all this just to say
how nice how genuinely nice it is to be
partners with join me during the
semester and partners in a deeper sense
because we are of course increasingly
active in in Brazil we are students of
Brazil and students in Brazil and so in
a way to have a great architect of
Brazil be it literally a teacher here in
the school is helping us to understand
in which way we would be students of of
Brazil as Brazil takes on this very
crucial leadership role Brazil of course
has long had this reputation of being
intensely beautiful and intensely
troubled and somehow these two stories
both both very stupid it seems to me and
both stop people from understanding the
extent to which Brazil is acting as an
incubator for new forms of intelligence
and if you're even half serious about
the future of cities you have to
understand cities in Brazil and you have
to understand what Brazilians are doing
and thinking about those cities and
that's where the real essence was cool
like us will have so this is why having
Jamie here today is such such a natural
way to begin our so-called Brazil week
and actually if Jamie's buses were
supposed to have 270 people but actually
have 300 Brazilians our week which
should be only seven days actually 10
days so we have 10 Brazilian days
starting with with with Jamie and going
through a whole series of films and
exhibitions and lectures and so on in a
way it's a kind of boot camp about the
relationship Brazil New York it's just
an attempt to synchronize our our
thoughts and our friendships and and
it's meant to act as a kind of a
platform you may or may not know but at
the same moment we are opening research
capacity in both in Rio and in sao paulo
with studio-x rio and sao paulo lab and
and in a sense we are looking for the
help of everybody in this room we have
no idea what's going to happen which is
why we call it X we have just have no
idea if we knew what was going to happen
we wouldn't be there what's absolutely
great about Brazil is impossible to know
what's going to happen it's one of the
places you'd be a fool if you thought
you knew what was going to happen we're
a different kind of fool and so we feel
we should be in the parts of the world
where our stupidity is greatest and
Brazil is one of those places anyway
long introduction stupid introduction to
a non stupid person Jamie
thank you it's it's being really a
pleasure on sharing so share with you
some ideas and and thanks to the people
that made his made this possible and but
I I'd like to start with story I use
every time when I'm going to someplace
and meeting mayor's planners
decision-makers I used to ask them what
about their city what's the problem so
most of the mayor's decision makers
planners they're saying oh weeks it's
impossible so far our to improve the
quality of life for City because it's
too big city there are other people try
to say our problem is education health
care and what is normal regarding
problems of cities after I used to make
a break and ask them ok now what's your
dream and I heading because some of them
they answered me the dream is solving
that kind of problems but this is not
enough what is really the dream or i
would say what is the scenario that
everyone every citizen
could understand this is a desirable
dream and they'll help you to make it
happen so always it has to be proposed a
dream I had this kind of ends were from
the governor in you know I have a jacket
the only one and the governor of Perm
Russia he answered me mom after saying
all the of showed me old all the is its
problems so okay so and he gave me an
idea that's my dream he asked me my
dream is at every every most of young
people I would like that they wouldn't
dream to move to Moscow because it's
close to Siberia and it's cold but it's
an interesting City so he gave me a good
answer good dream the mayor of Durango
Mexico his dream is the language should
be the logistic pole of Mexico I asked
him why because we have a good quality
of life and at the same time we were
close to the US North wear a very
important
in the middle of the road between
Missoula and Matamoros well it's a very
strategic position so and i asked him at
that time it was five years ago so do
you hell you dish had you had the chance
to speak with the candidates for
president in the u.s. about your idea
because of course he wanted to have
investments and not having to build a
wall between Mexico and the u.s. he
answered yes I I went to the other
candidates and I spoke to them so I
think most of the work I was involved is
on having dreams and how to make them
happen because after a long time I
realized that after working for almost
35 40 years in cities I realized that
every city in the world could improve
its quality of life in less than three
years no matter is the scale of the city
no matter is the financial condition of
the city you can really improve the
quality of life it depends of course
political will depend solidarity it
depends a strategy but mostly it depends
on how to build how to transform a
problem in solution how to organize a
good equation of chorus
possibility the other issues is it
possible to have a sustainable city I
realized that every city that has good
quality of life is they almost
sustainable that means because most of
the people they there is a concern about
sustainability of course there is a
concern about climate change but how to
make it happen so I went I am finishing
2,000 hours of seminars on
sustainability so I've been imagine many
meetings about new materials very
important but it's not enough or green
buildings oh it's but we cannot be so
naive Oh on having a green deal and
going from one green building to the
other green building and during the
itinerary will the trip will we won't
have a green city so it's important but
from now on it's important new sources
of energy that's not enough it's
important recycling reusing it's not
enough what is the key issue we have to
understand that seventy-five percent of
carbon emissions are related to the
cities it's the on the concept of the
city that we can be more effective and
it's very simple because everyone wants
to be sustainable banks as long as there
check the check
book it's from recycled materials they
advertising that the bank is sustainable
or the people living in gated
communities and they are planting some
trees in some pawar and many cities in
the world they're saying we're living in
a sustainable neighborhoods is not
sustainable and so the question is
understanding what makes the city more
sustainable using less the car your car
separating your garbage and most
important living close to your work
that's the key issue but the strategy I
would like to spend some time discussing
with you and one thing the more the best
example of quality of life for me is the
turtle because the toddler is has the
shell it's an example of living working
and moving together at the same time
Michelle of the third row looks like an
urban Tessa tool so can you imagine if
we get the cat the shell of the turtle
living here working here later here the
turtle she is going to die that's
exactly what we're doing with our series
separating functions separating people
by income by age by religions so I think
the term should be we should use or we
should dress t-shirts with the turtle
from now on but just another character
from a book that I wrote about 20 years
ago trying to explain the city poor
children
for teenagers or and this auto the
automobile it's a kind of guy woods
invited for to a party and he never
wants to live the chairs arm the table
and he never wants to live and he drinks
a lot and he caps a lot and at the same
time is a very agathis guy because he
cares only one or two or three people i
am repeating I know you know this the
saying that the car is like our mother
in law we should have good relationship
with our mother in law but we cannot
leave chic among our lives another hand
in the other hand if the only woman in
your life it's your mother-in-law you
have a big problem that's the Gordian
the friendly bus for the bandoneon for
the Argentineans it take care they can
care 300 people but as on the Sweden
rules is 270 it's 270 Sweden passengers
300 Brazilians but every every city has
a desire if his radio if his linear it
has to have some design in the city
curitiba has its design rio like two
birds kissing themselves or haha san
Francisco's very easy market street
vanasse the water from what is the
design it's a kind of strange
archaeology where we're trying to have
the
all trying to link old roads and some
spaces they they are we care of them and
linking them through a spy or which is a
structure of living working together and
moving together so that's the design of
Curitiba and it's the where we have more
density where we can offer better
quality of public transport and this are
the access where we have living working
moving everything and we have a good
public transport and this is you know by
the way the best best saying about
curitiba was given by a driver who
worked with me and the city hall and
after when I was a governor I asked him
let's go do you know Brasilia so he told
me no I have never been so let's go you
as well my plane you go so I i invite
you to go to Brasilia so what I he
answer me I never went i never went to I
never used the plane I never traveled in
a plane so cab so when the plane was an
uncertain hi he looked to the city of
Curitiba he told me it's it's like the
model
so that it's really for me it was
because it went many times so many
discussions we use the models of the
city to discuss then use and any it
looks like the model so and this is very
simple we didn't spend money on on on on
buying leg or arm expropriations we used
existing streets who put the express
buses in the central and that's its and
this are the de lines this is very close
to my house and this is the evolution of
the system we started in 74 with 25,000
passengers a day and this system is
being improved and improved and now we
are transporting two million and three
hundred thousand passengers a day which
is almost the number of the subway of
San Paulo and which is more passengers
than the subway of real and the railroad
and the superb railroad lines and it's
very simple what gave a good performance
to the system is this simple boarding
tubes where you can pay before entering
in the bus and you can board at the same
level it's like Metron izing a bus or
giving to the bus the same performance
than a subway and you see how it looks
is glass
you can bored easily and and there's a
few subway systems that they they don't
have facilities for handicapped and
every dismal cylinder it's the elevator
that provides accessibility to like any
other passenger but we started this idea
was it was in Rio when I worked for the
year 2000 project our idea was linking
the subway with the bus and this
connection will integrate the bus to the
subway at that time 25 years ago the
subway they were against and the private
company that they are running the buses
they were against and now 25 years after
they contracted us to develop the same
ideas so but what I even my feeling is
the future is on surface I don't want to
prove or to try to to go into this
discussion with which system is the best
i think if you have a subway you have to
have a smart subway if you have a bus
you have to have a SMART bus a smart
taxi which is the taxi of London where
you can board immediately or individual
or or you the bike if you have you have
to have a smart body and in France they
provided the bus as the bike as part of
a para tras
which is very clever and I'm working now
in a small car which is called doc doc
where you can have individual transport
with are not having are not having a not
owning the car it's cars without
ownership is the doc doc this develop
but what is the qizhong mobility never
never competing in the same space you
have to have its system should feed the
other one and this develop and this is
the doc lock it's the smallest car in
the world 60 centimeters per it's one
fourth of the size of the smart gun a
half of the width and a half of the
length and I can fit into this so this
was the first prototype the second
prototype death and now its most
improved the fourth were working the
fifth prototype and that's how it works
it's really small it's one sixth of the
size of the car and this is how it works
dot dot dot dot dot dr. so and how it
could be used in areas where you can
where you can have you can feed the
system the public system you can
organize better in downtown areas or in
some dedicated areas they can share with
the bike lanes they say because it has a
speed of 25 km/h and autonomy of 50
kilometers and this is the system in
real the project for the Olympic Games
it it has all the components subway be
Artie's any and by the way we started
the first one was in Curitiba 30 for 25
years after Bogota they did a wonderful
job wonderful work where the trans
millennia 89 and now we're having 81
cities implementing the BRTS including
Seoul Korea Mexico City many other
cities but the idea of how to integrate
its glass with LED
how it works this is the model you're
going to the concourse level and after
you it's the same system the vehicle is
different but you can imagine how it's
going to show how it's going to be in
the landscape of real at night during
the day it's not colored
ok
is it possible to have a city without
periphery that's the key issue how we're
taking advantage of a system of public
transport in favor of the city and that
was the challenge way we asked for in
the studio to every daniela and travel
and myself we asked the West Des teams
to propose how to link because the whole
idea is in San Paulo they are only for
subway lines and eighty-four percent of
the people the trips are on the surface
so we have to operate well the surface
but the suburb railroad to think they
are improving the system so why not
taking advantage of the network of the
suburb railroad and with a grand
promenade above the level of the of the
trains and in this prominent the area of
green area who could have the equivalent
of one I have Central Park the a of the
central park and the people they could
have a good quality of public transport
a promenade like a high line but huge
and in where you can link the new
buildings and you could have any kind of
income along this promenade
what is the key issue the big discussion
between the private initiative in San
Paulo and the public realm and the
government the city we're planning is
the private initiative there there is a
pressure to build always in the same
space so and this is it never there is
no way so they asked our group to say is
it possible to have an idea about the
design how the new design of San Paulo
how we could have new possibilities and
not having to pressure the same spaces
so we worked in a in this idea and
probably the studio here they are
working in better ideas but the ideas is
not it's not having a periphery you can
link to this promenade any kind of
income any kind of use and it could be
this way or you seen a 28 new ideas from
the Stooges there are all ideas having
bike lanes or the huge park and or the
letter car and and you could drink and
the private initiative having the
possibility to build higher building
they could pay this they could make it
feasible to pay this structure that
would link the whole city through a park
and that's the idea and here the
Mia University there are many many great
ideas from the studio which is being
linked with the real state area and
you're going to see in the next days but
that's there this was the challenge it's
not i'm not saying this is going to be
in this way it's a challenge how you
could link to this structure you'll see
many different and better ideas this in
downtown area the proposal we did but
let's go on to the discussion of
sustainability yes is it possible to
transform a city from a half square
meter of green area in a few years and
50 square meter of greenery repairing
that very innovative this was done
through very simple ways if we have time
we could detail how we could improve in
a few years to change from a half square
meter of green area Prairie habitat 250
and the population triples that means is
300 times more and the parts are that
we're having huge problems of floats in
Brazil one of the few cities that
doesn't have its Curitiba because you
organize the parks as a complex how to
control the level of the water and we
took all quarry's were recycled in this
the Open University for environment the
architecture is interesting it's
with what wooden wood wooden poles from
the energy companies when they they
change for concrete poles concrete poles
and and we we had a stock of wooden
poles all the architecture in the parks
is with treated poles and and this Terre
Haute anak garden how long it takes to
build a botanic garden and at years this
botanic garden was built in three months
but there is no miracle because we're
gonna plant 400 years but there is a
part of the Botanic Garden the that
could be used immediately and that's the
program of trading the whole program of
garbage that it's know how to we started
our buying garbage in places where is
difficult to access for the trucks and
you know now most of the disasters in
Rio are related to garbage that or was
thrown because there was no collect so
the whole idea is we proposed but we're
going to buy garbage as long as you
bring your garbage straight to the
tracks and from this program we started
after to separate the garbage and to
train garbage buy food and many is it
garbage is becoming a big issue in my
city but and we transformed a problem of
handed and third it that means in one
third of the problem because one third
is it's organic one third is organic
that
and be transfer Ghana garbage that can
be transformed income organic compost
and one-third is recyclable so it's just
be coming up and we teach the children
during six months in every school every
child and and this it was you know it's
not a program on the TV where you heard
the voice of God saying the government
of the city of Curitiba is doing that
death it's true the family leaves we did
you know the school's the children and
the children you're in six months and
after the children they teach their
parents and after we started the
campaign that's why since 20 years where
have the largest rate of separation of
garbage in the world sixty to seventy
percent of you and that's why I am
obsessed about the idea how to teach
sustainability to children we're
finished recently a movie of one year
ago it's a six-minute movie it's called
a convenient start is you can look at
the youtube and this shows how the
children how they can help how they can
understand about sustainability another
you should say okay it's important one
use less your car at least I'm not
saying don't use your car I'm saying at
least on routine i dinna rights and the
series they would have to provide the
goal
public transport useless your card
separate your garbage and live closer to
your work or bring work culture home and
also multiple use we know street fairs
but
but at night it's much better because
the families they meet and it's
incredible alive and another issues
about identity I used to say that one
you want creativity just cut 10 from
your budget if you want sustainability
cut two zeros from your budget if you
want solidarity keep your identity
respecting diversity and and you know a
series like our family portrait you
never rip your family portrait either
you if you don't like the nose of our an
ankle you don't rip your family potatoes
this portrait it's you and what is the
family portrait in a city some
references buildings all factories any
kind that helps you to have the
reference of the city this was no powder
house was transformed and a theater in
1971 the whole historic area which is
mostly German inference it was restored
their pedestrian mall you know the story
about it was implemented in 72 hours and
I I can tell you it's very important to
being fast why because one is to avoid
your own bureaucracy second it's one
once the decision making is done once
this discussion was done you have to do
it immediately
and the third is sometimes you have a
good to avoid insecurity but sometimes
you have a very good idea and you start
to think I probably this ideas not so
good because it's mine and you have to
understand that innovation is starting
you know I know people they feel more
safe or more secure if they have all the
answers but we cannot be soap reported
on having all the answers a
city-planning is like a transitory where
you cannot have all the answers you have
to leave some room to people they they
should correct you if you're not on the
run and the right track so and and it's
a tragedy you will net but most in many
cities the people they want to have all
the answers so that kind of cert
research origin and destiny where they
are projecting the tendency if you
project the tendency if you project the
tragedy tragedy you have the tragedy
that's that's not a big deal only having
this kind of survey so I you can write a
whole tray take how to sweep move your
arms and legs at the same time but at
the moment when your dive in the water
ah it was so easy when I was a teenager
I used to read rotate about sex so after
I realized oh it's not so difficult
so that's the place where were short the
history of the city and you know the
creative as 317 its edge 370 17 years
and during the 300th anniversary we
wanted to pay homage to our ethnic
contribution like here New York big
ethnic contribution so it was a
competition of the portal for the
Italians and the Ukrainian park and
polish park were the Pope he went to
Curitiba was wonderful in nineteen
eighty I was having a drink with some
friends and I I was made at that time I
had told the guys look I have to leave
because I have a meeting with the Pope I
had this meet the distal pulse park and
the Japanese square and the german park
and since we have people from everywhere
from Uzbekistan alcazar kiss tongue
coldest tea cookies kissed and so we had
to stop the program because we didn't
have money enough but I I realized that
there are some places that they are very
ugly in the city but they can be
transformed in varied in beautiful
places this was a quarry turbo quarry
this quarry was transformed and a
beautiful building at the Open
University of environment this another
quarry that that was transformed in and
the theater
and it was two months it took the works
and it was built legally so we made a
bit just for the material another bid
for the main power in two months within
the theater and it looks it's a
beautiful theater or this landfill is
becoming a beautiful park it started
this adventure when I would like to give
you some examples about acupuncture
sometimes planning takes time and it has
to take time but sometimes you can true
some focal point focal ideas you can
provide a new energy that could help the
whole process of planning it's what I
call urban acupuncture it's not instead
of the process of planning it's to help
the process of bread and I give you some
beautiful examples of beautiful
acupuncture's in France the en face de
louvre is solved with one jest it's all
problems of centuries and this the most
beautiful park in New York the paley
part is 30 meters / 32 meters it has not
to be baked this Niemeyer's museum in
curitiba it's really beautiful museum or
some acupuncture that our office we're
doing this is the pavilion the bossa
nova park and we're where we'll we'll
have the whole story of the bossa nova
you know bossa nova is the soundtrack of
it's like a keyboard with the balance of
the waves of the sea dulce balance domak
and that's the story it's going to show
they're starting they're going to start
this building and but some ideas some of
them were they fit he parted big car
racer in Brazil he asked for a project
about mobility about speed this is free
speed and that was the idea about the
museum of a mobility sustainable museum
is true some games we try to show the
chip teach the children how long it
takes how many carbon emissions from
from their house to the school in one
trip in in one year and ten years and it
will show and the ozone layer of that
was the idea and in the cube the artist
will will show will explain will teach
the children about sustainability
and this is the project we did for some
Paul didn't work but it's a huge park
above the buildings that will link to
the park the loose it's a beautiful
place and this is a kind of key where we
try to link the area of the market big
marketing support but the idea i want to
show you it's sometimes you have a place
which is the game so how long it will
take to restore houses to make it more
because revitalizing is bringing its
living again bringing life so people
they won't move because we have the
three best anchors cultural anchors of
some paul the pinnacle tech the museum
of portuguese language the auditorium
but the area it's called cracklin it's
terrible it's very so how could we bring
life again to this area the idea was
true portable streets to bricks because
nobody wants to live in desire because
there is no street life it is bringing
street life on Friday night and removing
the portable street on Monday morning in
during the week the portable street was
will be in the front of a university and
this is another acupuncture it's a
theater in Campinas and this
a project will I was appointed by oscar
niemeyer to propose for the 50th
anniversary of brasilia how to organize
the satellite cities because you have a
very formal city which is the pilot way
it looks like a plane close to the lake
but its formal and how could we give a
form to the chaotic agglomeration of
Brazilian where we have people living
500,000 people living in part in the
pilot plate and two men and a 500,000
people living outside and working in
this area so it takes two hours to go
home and it shouldn't be that way so we
proposed an a design for the satellite
cities which is a kind of analogy of the
metaphor of the plane and with the belt
that the this is the design of the
bottom by the valleys in the parts and
we should have the new buildings along
the edge of the parks and there were it
we're going to have one just one bulova
linking the two parts the formal and the
new area the new place through this
green buildings and the portable streets
and this this
the street this Boulevard this apart
we've made the project sometimes some
parts are over built because they think
they have to build all the parts and the
built fences the best offense is a
cycleway and you don't have to spend a
fortune and just with four or five
points you can have a beautiful part you
should have some room to the landscape
and not try to build the whole park and
that's the idea you know the product in
and valencia of the Umbra come from
calatrava it's G color Travis a genius
but you know we didn't have the money to
build a knob rattle and structure their
own Brockton with it as a shame square
of shake it with bouquets of bamboos
very simple very low the cost is nothing
and I have an architect will works in my
office he knows everything about bamboos
he knows when the bamboo is has
depression when the bhabua said he knows
when you have to cut the bamboo and that
that's dish the square of shade in this
part and this we recycled an old system
they're all reservoir water from the
city it was transformed in a museum and
there's one thing being sustainable it's
not spending it's not wasting you know
some exhibitions park of exhibits center
of exhibitions
so the ex they asked us to build a place
for 10,000 people so you're not going to
you crazy you're not going to build a
plate for 10,000 people you have a
wonderful climate wonderful patches why
not having just small for all the terms
and when you will have the need for
10,000 people they can you can just be
in the end there in the patio you don't
have to spend and this is the design we
are doing for Luanda Angola it's it's
incredible it's just the hope you see
they're walking area but our contract
was how to make better the streets and
we deserve this areas in this incredible
the people are going at night they sting
is the whole night in those streets they
like in this are some of the project
with it for the world oh this is a place
in the vid is the second city in Panama
and they have a kind of sanctuary and so
only with the design of the steps who
could have this landscape so during the
processions everyone could have it's not
urban furniture it's human furniture so
it's you the only design are the steps
this recent project we did in santiago
was Cavaliers we made a charrette one
which are and we worked with the
architects of the city politicians on as
students and their the question was how
to save the big river that crosses the
whole city is the 505
sorry if this city the second city in
the Dominican Republic and how to save
the river so at the end of this week we
propose two ideas their way how to save
the river and also the Rio pyaar ki at
the end we finished singing a merengue
about a yucky and an adult airport we
transform the ideas nursery abuse and
the Botanic Garden a place for the
plants and the other side is for shows
normally a place for shows is just like
a parking area but we design the cameras
how you see the special the we design
the columns that gave the perspective of
a theater it's not a parking place and
there are n it's going to be a beautiful
place so to ideas and other as another
witch's us how every every turn it will
show 50 years of the anniversary of the
city and this is now the last project we
are doing in Mazatlan it's an island in
front of the old city and it's a place
with zero cards and with that our
proposal is not to touch the jewels not
to touch the
station just keeping not touching the
terrain and it's going to be this way
zero car just bicycles letter cars
horses and of course vaporetto linking
their old city with the island and this
is there with the they have an interest
interesting thing which is its module
the whole island is module with palm
trees every 10 meters so we took
advantage of this design and we proposed
a whole sustainable way how to have all
the places and at the same time their
infrastructure and this is interesting
they have a hill that was cut and they
took the rocks to build the pier but the
cutter half of the hill since the
program they wanted our hotel and not
having to build a huge hotel in a so
beautiful place we proposed how to
fulfill the landscape of the hill with
the hotel it's going to look this way
okay now it's the idea of the portable
streets it's like the idea came from
Paris their bikinis it's so we designed
this idea which is at the same time a
module for the portable street bus
shelter and instead a working station
hotels in airports are resting place in
our airports living and working stations
the doctor living working
and that is the idea the proposal where
did for real with the portal in the port
or the lappa area and this is the
prototype and this is during the
festival of theater who have 12
prototypes now let's go we're going to
build really in large scale and it's a
beautiful you could put coffee store or
a beautiful store of Brandis for you
know it's LED and it's they have
beautiful windows button this is a
module for the airport and this is the
turtleman my dream is having the house
in my back and this is the way how
Turtles a thing so to finishing I'm in
the year 97 who we organized we didn't
have olympic games in that year or work
up or any kind of of games so we wanted
to organize the world nature gapes we
had just six months to organize but we
organized this games we had 40 countries
hundred NTV 20 TV stations showing the
word games of nature we didn't spend one
set in building stadiums gymnasiums
because the place was the nature
ballooning rusting climbing the water
from the waterfall driving the wall from
the waterfall so
this is sustainability or we didn't have
and we have 399 monies parties in my
state with some moneys parts from 3000
5000 people wouldnt have money to build
theatres so we organized a cultural
convoy we took 10 buses we recycled them
10 old buses 140 / 148 award for music
one for dance 14 circles and we had a
nap ended during five years the culture
convoy travelled along all the roads of
the state and we had an average of
thousand and two hundred people every
show so let me you could turn on the
lights please let me finish with one say
I'm convinced after all these years I
convinced that it's possible you can do
it all you need this to propose an idea
a scenario that everyone understand it
is desirable if they understand it is
desirable they'll help you to make it
happen so I'm a very lucky man I could
make many of my dreams come true I'm not
saying political dreams or professional
grapes I'm saying normal dreams so I
realized one thing some if sometimes you
cannot make your deep field ring come
true don't be frustrated if you dedicate
yourself deeply to your dream you can be
sure that one day one time this dream
will turn around you will hit you and
we'll ask you you remember me I'm your
dream it's your second chance don't
throw it away thank
like I talked about you toronto ontario
he talked of acupuncture the new city
hall was built in nineteen sixty-five
i'm sure you're familiar with it yeah I
finish architect Ravel i can't pronounce
his first name he died before it was
completed but that sort of revitalized
the whole city tarana while i was there
less than 95 I hear it's very like what
you talk about very active very people
friendly I've been there many times very
good trance good subways good bosses and
its really people friendly and
ecologically friendly so that might be a
city that you would agree with you agree
I I went 1-2 Toronto and the mayor it
took me for a right and yes and he told
me through the expressway which is
almost in front of the waterfront almost
in the water flow and he told me he was
planning to remove the water the freeway
because everything behind the free
weights becoming is becoming the king is
the K so okay and and I realized one
thing when we were traveling in the
freeway it's very speed where I speak so
but at the moment when we had to leave
to speak the freeway and to go to the
normal path of the city it took us more
than one hour to live the freeway so
sometimes the freeway is the fastest way
to bring you from one place from one
jumped area to an
Jeb them but I i agree with you it's a
great city sir and and Vancouver's
incredible great great city they still
have a strip with movie theaters in
Vancouver they still have they don't
have a problem they have shopping center
with movies number one number two number
three jobs number 17 but they have still
all movie theaters where you can see we
can watch normal movies not serial
killers by the way i never saw a movie
in france or in spain Oh shown you how
to destroy the Louvre or how to destroy
the Torah fell I never saw how to
destroy the not reedham why here in this
country you'd like to show how to
destroy your great places I don't know
their true
patna question any question
portable street market stalls sorry how
what the cost the cost well you can I
don't remember but the unit is it's
about three thousand four thousand
dollars view the model $3,000 the model
but I can send you two for two thousand
two electric it's a big concept I'm not
a car designer I'm terrible another
color they might what what attracts me
it's it's a concept so let's say if you
buy a Chevrolet or volvo car or
mitsubishi car you earn five hundred
hours in the dot lock so it's not
against the car it's providing a new
alternative how to feed public transport
with individual it's darking wise is
dark as her cell phone that's the idea
what is the news last week i want where
i was discussing with the energy company
the biggest energy company on
distribution of energy and they want to
invest to build this car because they
they can provide the energy so they
asked us study for 20 cities how to put
public transport how to link with some
lines of of the doc doc considering of
course they are sins were they are
working where they are the
riveters of the energy but it's an idea
what strikes me it's is not only
changing are changing for an electric
engine for an electric car because you
have to have in mind that you have to
have clean energy second it's it's not
okay you can save you can better not
having pollution with electric cars but
it wouldn't solve the problem of
mobility just changing from the engine
you have to have a concept how to use
this this gadget so I think your last
question
the beautiful river and a flip
free-flowing freeway but I was wondering
that river is quite polluted and freeway
is quite congested and what steps the
city is taking to alleviate those
problems in because if you have a park
along the rivers no one's going to be
able to use it if it's congested and all
right I'm sorry you sure a beautiful
river and a beautiful freeway but three
ways actually congested in the river is
actually polluted is the city gonna I
didn't show the freeway they I showed a
park above their railroad path super
blind path is not the freeway okay
second the river is not clean but there
is a way how to make it three so the
better you use the river the clean air
it will come the problem is all the
project they want to build a whole
project in that I showed you the example
of the city santiago de los Caballeros
they were more important considering the
scale of the city it's more important
for them than any of the rivers from
some Paul so what happens is it's dirty
but we know the feeder rivers or feeder
how to say feeder streams yeah we know
it's five or six okay so it's impossible
to do all the works okay first of all
avoid avoid to start to clean the big
river so in the moment the small river
comes to the big one you have to start a
small tree treatment
and from this place so you you in six
with six small stations you can provide
you can clean the river and after you
have time to work for 20 years to clean
all how they say the Canada's the bottom
valet is how to clean but in a few
months you can have the whole river the
big river clean that's important so the
question is drainage big problems or
polish drainage when they have big rains
the it's the it's there is no there is
no drainage enough they have their image
of course but the speed everything is
paid there is no way how to absorb the
water and we're working in some ideas
we'll see in a few months some ideas how
to at least help to solve the problem
I'm not but some of the disasters we had
in Rio recently it was because they
moved they change the word in the
terrain so they threw the garbage most
some of the slides it was like sliding
garbage that kills okay the other issue
is doing some work on sewage treatment
or water supply or energy my feeling is
not to touch the terrain you can have a
very low income very low cost
infrastructure
not touching the terrain the idea was
when we worked a long time ago in
Caracas the idea was using the rails
Nick men under say the Henry from the
stairs we use the hand raised from the
stairs for water supply energy excuse me
and the sewage throat the stairs that
they are they give you the access to the
hills so true there and read you can
leap but not
I can tell you it won't solve all the
problems of course not but some of the
problem they could sort through this way
okay last question
in New York City as far as Times Square
goes where 50 years ago as a student
here it was that was one of the problems
we did as far as making it open to
pedestrians and so forth I was taking 50
years to get to some place today where
it's going on today and it seems that
architects are not involved and have
never been that prevents process of it
you know it's been the Robert Moses not
architect non-planar say to a Jane
Jacobs who had to tell us all about it
and well so I was wondering where does
the influence of the for the power you
want to call it maybe of the architect
planner how can they get into it or are
we just continually just making a pretty
drawings of wonderful buildings and
that's how we're way known as well i
hope you'll leave for more 50 years for
to see if something is happening my my
feeling is I've met many good mayor's
all over the world many good governors
the problem is when regarding the cities
that they like they delegate to the
barakah see and because it's okay where
I take care of it with politics but this
when you're dealing with the city you
cannot delegate you have to take this
and do it because a bureaucrat he has
the whole life he has the whole life he
doesn't carry us he has no commitment to
the city has no commitment to the mayor
care probably he wants to finish his
doctorate PhD and and as long as he's in
work it's okay for him and most of them
they are very good professionals Oh all
they need is a push as commitment and
but a mayor cannot delegate when
regarding fundamental issues but I am
now a part of my life and I decided to
having fun having fun is doing
acupuncture because I can finish in 1
i'm going with three for architects
assemblies in one week i finish i don't
have to achill discuss big contracts I
don't want to sell consultant charges my
idea is let's make a charrette let's
work together and at the end we'll leave
one or two ideas if you understand if
you like these ideas you can do by
yourself or you have a team of
professionals in the place or we can
help them to make it happen if they
don't like the idea there is no loss of
money in orders of time and we just
charge a trip and a certain fee by
professional but I don't have to discuss
with bureaucracy big contracts I hate
this I am NOT dying the city of so
Paulo they are doing a big bid to
contract big big offices to do what
bureaucracy if it's a competition of
would of course I would took part but
spending two years to make bureaucracy
and being well paid but what what's the
what's the point so when I was president
of the UAE it was the worst job I had
because his 1,000,000 they said it was
1,200,000 architects in the world
1,200,000 egos but I realized that we
made 11 idea it was the idea was the
celebration of cities which was that in
every city there's the architects
professionals that they have a good idea
for their own City why not having a
competition of ideas and we organize the
competition all over the world as 400
series we had it was beautiful and it's
compared the Italian section of the UI
is taking care of the competition now
every two years it is great I it's all
you I like the discussion when it starts
with an idea and an assembly it's better
when you start with an idea or if you
are against over it depend it's a game
sometimes the community they start
sometimes it's a government sometimes as
the premise doesn't matter it has to be
it has to have a start and I won't take
more time from you and thank